[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
welcome to flavortown I see you found
the tequila that I left for you
are you guys more like a Yeti hey hey
what's this girl gonna do huh was this
gal gonna do she gonna boys she gonna
poison us with tasty treats on a
completely unrelated topic can I
interest you ladies in a delicious fresh
made Triple D milkshake um we don't
accept drinks from random strangers yeah
no thanks
we've got a countdown to do yeah come on
what is the food round here these are
the top five worst Sandra Bullock
performances number five
premonition this thriller released in
2007 failed to engage in thrill many
including Bullock
she plays Linda a woman who learns that
her husband has died in a tragic car
accident when she wakes up the next
morning he is back alive and it is days
before the accident she must pieced
together what happens and how to stop
his untimely death all while living the
days in a mixed-up order it is just as
jumbled and nonsensical as it sounds the
movie tried so hard to be gripping and
intriguing and that was part of the
problem you could feel it was trying to
be clever there's really only so much an
actress can do when presented with bad
material but Bullock swings between
under and overacting throughout the film
sometimes she barely shows emotion as
these huge events past let me show you
here's her reacting to learning her
husband has died here's her meeting her
husband's possible mistress do something
we should be talking about
something involving my husband hears her
making underhanded comments about him
dying soon because apparently there
needs to be some humor in this movie
besides it could be good for us you know
take a break from each other break the
new bargain lastly here's her learning
from a priest that this is all her fault
because she doesn't have faith wait what
some people thought they suffered from
what the ancients called blasphemer a
absense Phoebus the dangers of the
faithless overall Bullock tries her best
to save premonition but just doesn't
have the foresight to pull it off number
four forces of nature unfortunately for
everyone this movie forced a lot of
tropes with little payoff Sandra Bullock
plays Sarah an edgy woman who plays fast
and loose you can tell she's edgy
because she's got a purple streak in her
hair and takes risks in life like going
to jail and yelling at the top of a
train some of the acting choices in this
aren't bad so much as they are strange a
lot of her interactions with other
characters were heightened for comedic
effect but it just felt so over the top
it was difficult to comprehend why
people let her get away with it like
when she's decked with a computer and
she turns into the consistency of wet
spaghetti Bullock does her best with
some strange dialogue but the direction
doesn't help
alright there's this theme that a flex
character is drawn to Bullock because of
forces beyond his control obviously
against his wishes because he's getting
married and she's just so quirky and
different obviously being young and
beautiful was such a disservice for her
any movie that is able to make Sandra
Bullock seem uncharismatic has taken
some grave missteps number three two
weeks notice two weeks notice
was two weeks too long Bullock plays
Lucy Kelson a granola hippie attorney
who starts working for real estate
tycoon George Wade played by Hugh Grant
Lucy becomes everything she once hated
even leaving her best friend's wedding
at the drop of a hat unhappy in her
overbearing work environment
Lucy longs to return to her grass roots
and tenders her resignation
unfortunately way it consistently
depends on Lucy for everything from
picking outfits to licking envelopes
he's charmingly befuddled of her
feminine wiles and she slowly worn down
into falling for him too when Wade slips
into his old playboy ways it's hard to
root for Lucy to pursue him in addition
their chemistry is incredibly platonic
so a lot of the romantic moments feel
unnaturally forced there are some very
specific bad character choices sprinkled
throughout the movie like melting after
having water spilled on her and laughing
at senior activities at the community
center but most notably the running gag
of ordering food for one can I get the
number four without the garlic sauce
okay and then maybe two orders of number
number 26 and yes is for one her
over-the-top character that's able to
shift on a dime makes her seem like she
has no backbone rather than someone torn
between her heart and brain number two
Miss Congeniality 2 the first Miss
Congeniality is arguably one of Sandra
Bullock's most fun movies to watch
Gracie Hart is frustrating yet lovable
with loads of compassion and
stubbornness to share unfortunately
the sequel missed the mark on why we
couldn't get enough of her antics in
Miss Congeniality choo Gracie Hart is no
longer able to work undercover as her
previous assignment for the Miss United
States pageant left her as a household
name the FBI decides to embrace her
notoriety and get her a book deal and
for some reason a team of stylists to
follow her around on the inevitable book
tour
WTF be I when Miss United States gets
kidnapped
Sandra must put her new identity on hold
and go undercover once again to save her
friend this includes dressing up as a
senior citizen performing as a showgirl
and attacking Dolly Parton some of the
advice she gives is heartbreaking
I would really love to but as you can
see the agency's got me pretty busy
there you go thank you very much but
what you could do is just pull your hair
up every once in a while it would really
open up your face because remember
people care about people who care about
themselves and it feels like they took
the fight out of her not that you're a
dog they generally have smoother hair
look just you know just tell me what you
want me to do and I'll do it there's
still some funny moments but this sequel
trimmed all of her rough edges that made
her unique and left her shellacked with
gimmicks which made her less relatable
and fun to follow and the number one
worst Sandra Bullock performance is
all about Steve audiences and critics
were baffled by Bullock's performance as
Mary in this trainwreck of a movie all
about Steve follows the developing
relationship between Mary and the
titular character Steve the problem is
that Mary is actually a stalker
like a legitimate threat to Steve his
job and his sanity Mary is a quirky
crossword puzzle creator for her local
paper that follow Steve across the
country after he tries to let her down
gently
after a short awkward blind date life on
the road sure is awful she would be
great if he could be out there with me
what makes this character truly awful is
her limited development as a person her
only trait is that she's quirky the
movie is constantly screaming look isn't
she's so fun and unique she's so random
it's like the director wanted her to be
a Manic Pixie dream girl but without all
the charm Bullock is way over the top
and borderline creepy throughout the
whole movie
Larry thanks for not raping me
my pleasure although it did allow her to
make history as the first person to ever
win a Razzie and Academy Award in the
same year so I guess that's something
time to turn up the heat and get cooking
with some delicious snacks couldn't have
said it better myself guys playing with
Walter 2.0 again no we were playing with
Walter 2.0 Michael Caine again but it
was so real guys want to watch the
Lakers
[Music]
[Applause]
you